because the only way to change a
scenario is to do it different
you know the thing about people is
they'd be like oh why is it always
happening this way because you [ __ ]
do it the same way every day right you
react the same way
you move the same i mean how do you
expect a different result if you're not
doing anything different
you know so i decided to approach it a
different way
you know i wrote like letters and [ __ ]
and then it worked itself out but at the
end of the day what i know is i'm never
gonna ever let anything that's bothering
me
faster faster because that causes
sadness which causes cancer it's not
healthy to be unhappy laughter is key as
well
laughter is key man i feel like yeah i
mean just being here for the last few
hours i feel like you've you kind of
have a great environment for creatives
here for just
it's nothing it's a vibe in here man
this is what this is you know sometimes
you got to machiavelli yourself for
peace
and i needed people to leave me to [ __ ]
alone so i could actually work on me
and architect the environment that i
could do daily to the extent that i
don't even see time i can't i'm like 50.
i'm like what the [ __ ] how'd that happen
i don't feel 50. i don't feel i might
have so much fun it's more fun than when
i was 20. wow it's crazy it says a lot
man that's why people should invest in
their future
see when i was 25 i looked at what i
wanted to be doing in 25 years i was
like i'm definitely not gonna be trying
to shake a [ __ ] bottle on the stage
you know i did that
way right of course of course
i just saw you reenact the uh the dame
dash dance from that's the only way it
was happening bro i just saw that i was
like yo you nailed it like and then i
just thought it was dance i'm not i know
[ __ ] but i was like
you would have thought it was it was it
was 99 or 2000 again it's my dad
if i ever can't do my own dance that's
real [ __ ] up
and it's like it's like it's it's as
much of a dance as it's just like a
moment it's like
it's a lot of moments bro if you notice
it was like it's the dame dash dance is
like 30 different dances it was every
time i [ __ ] danced in a video and it
got captured it was just
you know
me being free how is what freedom looks
like that dance